>>> PRESIDENT BIDEN TODAY
PROMISED HE'S DOING EVERYTHI
HE CAN TO TAME INFLATION AND
BRING DOWN PRICES FOR AMERICANS.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS RUSSIA IS TO
BLAME, ALSO OIL COMPANIES AND
SHIPPING AS WELL AS REPUBLICANS.
LET'S BRING IN OUR KAITLAN
COLLINS.
SHE IS COVERING THE PRESIDENT
OUT IN LOS ANGELES RIGHT NOW.
KAITLIN, THE WHITE HOUSE IS
AWARE THIS INFLATION COULD MAKE
OR BREAK THE DEMOCRATS COMING UP
IN THE MIDTERMS AND PRESIDENTIAL
CONTEST FOR US DOWN THE ROAD.
>> WOLF, IT'S A BIG
VULNERABILITY FOR THIS PRESIDENT
AND FOR HIS PARTY.
OF COURSE, YOU SAW HIM TODAY NOT
EVEN TRY TO SUGARCOAT THE
NUMBERS BECAUSE REALLY, THERE IS
NO SUGARCOATING TO BE DONE GIVEN
IT WAS A VERY UNPLEASANT
SURPRISE FOR THE WHITE HOUSE
HOPING THESE NUMBERS WOULD
MODERATE SLIGHTLY IN MAY AND OF
COURSE, THEY ACCELERATED AND
WHEN YOU HEARD FROM PRESIDENT
BIDEN TODAY, HE DIDN'T MAKE
PREDICTIONS WHEN INFLATION IS
GOING TO START TO GO DOWN AND
INSTEAD, HE TRIED TO EMPATHIZE
WITH AMERICANS WHO ARE FEELING
THE PAIN.
>> I UNDERSTAND AMERICANS ARE
ANXIOUS AND ANXIOUS FOR GOOD
REASON.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT BIDEN
STARING DOWN A MASSIVE POLITICAL
LIABILITY.
>> MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT.
I UNDERSTAND INFLATION IS A REAL
CHALLENGE TO AMERICAN FAMILIES.
>> Reporter: NEW DATA SHOWS
CONSUMER PRICES SOARED LAST
MONTH SENDING INFLATION CLIMBING
8.6% FROM LAST YEAR, THE HIGHEST
SINCE 1981.
BIDEN DELIVERING THE BAD NEWS
TODAY AFTER PREDICTING SIX
MONTHS AGO THE INFLATION CRISIS
HAD HIT THE PEAK.
>> I THINK YOU'LL SEE IT CHANGE
SOONER AND QUICKER AND MORE
RAPIDLY THAN IT WILL TAKE --
THAN MOST PEOPLE THINK.
>> Reporter: PRICES ARE HIGHER
FROM FOOD, FUEL, RENT, TO USED
CARS AS BIDEN OFFICIALS SAY THAT
TAMING INFLATION IS THEIR
HIGHEST PRIORITY.
>> WE ARE OPEN TO IDEAS.
AGAIN, SOME OF THEM REQUIRE
WORKING WITH CONGRESS.
THE PRESIDENT IS FOCUSED ON
LOWERING COSTS FOR FAMILIES.
>> Reporter: BUT THOSE SAME
OFFICIALS SAY THAT THE BULK OF
THE RESPONSE WILL FALL TO THE
FEDERAL RESERVE AS FRIDAY'S
NUMBERS ONLY OFFER MORE REASON
FOR THE CENTRAL BANK TO CONTINUE
RAISING INTEREST RATES.
>> AS PART OF HIS PLAN, I KNOW
THIS DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A PLAN
BUT FIRST AND FOREMOST, HE
RESPECTS THE INDEPENDENCE OF THE
FEDERAL RESERVE.
>> Reporter: IT COULD SPELL DOOM
THIS NOVEMBER AS BIDEN LASHED
OUT AT REPUBLICANS SHIPPING,
PRESIDENT PUTIN AND OIL
COMPANIES TODAY.
>> EXXON MADE MORE MONEY THAN
GOD THIS YEAR.
>> Reporter: THE PRESIDENT
HAVING A LOT OF CRITICISM THERE,
WOLF, AS HE WAS COMMENTING ON
THE NEW NUMBERS.
ONE THEY HOPED WOULD GO DOWN IS
PRICES ON CONSUMER GOODS.
YOU SAW PRESIDENT BIDEN SPEAKING
AT THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES TODAY
DURING HIS TRIP HERE TO THE WEST
COAST.
OF COURSE, THOSE NUMBERS ARE
STILL HIGH JUST AS THE REST THAT
WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT WOLF
AND YES, THIS IS GOING TO
POTENTIALLY HAVE A DRAG ON
DEMOCRATS IN THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
THAT'S THE CONCERN YOU HEAR FROM
A LOT OF PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
ALLIES ON CAPITOL HILL BECAUSE
WE'RE JUST FIVE MONTHS AWAY FROM
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS AND LOOK
AT THIS POLL THAT CAME OUT THIS
WEEK.
YOU SEE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
APPROVAL NUMBERS ARE A LOT LOWER
THAN THEY WERE WHEN HE FIRST
TOOK OFFICE BUT THE WEAKEST
POINT IS ON THE ECONOMY WHERE HE
GETS A 28% APPROVAL RATING,
WOLF.
THESE ARE THE NUMBERS THE WHITE
HOUSE IS VERY WORRIED ABOUT WHEN
IT COMES TO THE INFLATION
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT IT WAS
GOING TO START GOING DOWN BY
NOW.
OF COURSE, YOU SAW OFFICIALS
LIKE THE TREASURY SECRETARY TO
YOU SAYING THEY GOT IT WRONG
WHEN THEY SAID THEY THOUGHT
INFLATION WOULD BE TEMPORARY.
OBVIOUSLY, IT'S STILL HERE
SEVERAL MONTHS LATER SO NOW,
THEY'RE TRYING TO